nos dicen un cuidador de zoológico toma
una muestra aleatoria de 30 días en los
cuales observa cuánta comida como un
elefante en cada uno de esos días la
media fue de 350 kilogramos y la
desviación estándar de la muestra fue de
25 kilogramos el intervalo de confianza
resultante del 90 por ciento para la
media de la cantidad de comida fue y
bueno me dan este intervalo desde 341
kilogramos hasta 359 kilogramos cuál de
las siguientes afirmaciones es una
interpretación correcta del nivel de
confianza del 90% bueno pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo bueno ahora lo vamos a
resolver juntos antes incluso de leer
estas opciones necesitamos estar seguros
de entender qué nos dice esta
información un cuidador del zoológico
intenta averiguar el valor esperado de
la cantidad de alimento que consumirá un
elefante en un día
pero como el promedio de comida que
consume un elefante al día si ves la
cantidad de comida en cada uno de todos
los posibles días como la población
total entonces puedes entender esto como
la media de la población es decir la
media de la cantidad de comida diaria
ahora el cuidador no sabe todo esto es
por ello que toma una muestra aleatoria
de 30 días justo lo que nos dicen aquí
así que veamos lo de esta forma si por
aquí tengo la media de la población es
decir la media de la cantidad de comida
que consume un elefante al día entonces
lo que hace el cuidador es tomar una
muestra en este caso toma una muestra de
30 días y realizó un estadístico de la
muestra en el cual obtuvo una media de
la muestra de 350 kilogramos ojo no
sabemos si están a la derecha oa la
izquierda del verdadero parámetro así
que supongamos que
justo por aquí esta va a ser mi media
muestral de esta primera muestra y ya
sabemos que valen 350 kilogramos ahora
usando esta muestra construyó un
intervalo de confianza de 341 a 359
kilogramos así que lo voy a poner justo
así no sabemos si en verdad incluye el
valor real de la media o no como lo
estoy dibujando aquí pero supongamos que
es así el punto de tener un intervalo de
confianza del 90% es que si nos
mantenemos haciendo más muestras por
ejemplo esta es nuestra primera muestra
y el intervalo asociado con esta muestra
si hicieran otra muestra por aquí
esta muestra tiene su respectiva media
que supongamos que es esta y además
tiene su intervalo asociado que voy a
suponer que es este de aquí donde no
solamente cambiaría la media o los
valores del intervalo
puede ser que el tamaño del intervalo
también cambie eso dependerá de cómo se
comporte me muestra entonces lo que nos
dice un intervalo de confianza de un 90
por ciento es que si nos mantenemos
haciendo esto si nos mantenemos haciendo
muestras el 90 por ciento de mis
intervalos de confianza incluirán el
valor real del parámetro en este caso la
media poblacional que este de aquí ahora
con esto en mente veamos cuál de las
opciones es consistente con lo que
acabamos de decir inciso a los elefantes
comieron entre 340 y 1 kilogramos y 359
kilogramos el 90% de esos días
en definitiva no es lo que buscamos no
estamos hablando de lo que pasa el 90%
de los días por lo tanto vamos a
cancelar esta opción inciso b existen
una 0.90 de probabilidad de que la
verdadera media de la cantidad de comida
esté entre 340 y 1 kilogramos y 359
kilogramos bueno esta opción es bastante
interesante y me parece atractiva porque
cuando hacemos una muestra puedes decir
bien si hacemos muchas de estas muestras
el 90% de ellas tendrán un intervalo de
confianza que incluya la media verdadera
de la población la única razón del por
qué me parece inadecuada esta opción es
que hace parecer que la verdadera media
está de aquí es una variable aleatoria
parece que pudiera cambiar de valor
parece que puede estar o no puede estar
incluida en este intervalo y es por ello
que todo un poco
esta opción así que déjame ponerle
signos de interrogación bien veamos qué
dice el inciso ser en un muestreo
repetido me empieza agradar esto
este método produce intervalos si eso es
lo que estamos haciendo cada vez que te
tomas una muestra esta muestra produce
un cierto intervalo es cierto que
incluyen la media de la población cerca
del 90% de las muestras sin perfecto es
justo lo que estábamos diciendo si nos
mantenemos haciendo esto y construimos
de manera adecuada el intervalo de
confianza entonces el 90% de estos
intervalos incluirán a la media
verdadera así que si me gusta bastante
esta opción y veamos qué dice la opción
de para no dejarla de lado en un nuestro
repetido este método produce una media
de la muestra entre 341 kilogramos y 359
kilogramos en un 90% de las muestras
el intervalo de confianza no pone una
restricción de que el 90% de las veces
la media muestral esté entre estos dos
parámetros así que voy a cancelar esta
opción voy a cancelar este inciso de y
en definitiva la opción correcta am es
el inciso cm hasta la próxima